got a lot of stuff to put away before if
you come come look at my place
first oh thanks guess it's first ooh
this is cute it's nice is it the same
size
yeah yeah i think so okay
for us getting identical apartments is
usually how we do things
we like the same vibe we like luxury we
like brand new
but some of the things i definitely
don't want to hear when i'm passing
stacy's door
is i don't know doing the dirty deed
it's cozy i like it georgie's coming
tomorrow
so i gotta get a lot done and oh he's
coming tomorrow
yeah wow i mean
as long as you're not rushed into it i
mean i'm just not about
you know trying to waste time in another
relationship i want to see where this
goes and if this is
the right one then i'll know
honestly i would never lock myself in an
apartment during quarantine with a guy
that i've only been on a couple dates
with it's just to me it's just
it's too much of a risk and i don't know
georgie he seems like a nice guy but
you know i don't really know what his
intentions are
[Music]
you guys are like basically like moving
in with each other and you guys just
met pretty much stacy we didn't just
meet and we've already connected
i just want him to be closer by so we
can work on our relationship at the same
time
you know so it doesn't work out
this is the true test